welcome back SCP explained viewers we
hope you're all having a terrible day
I'm sorry my mistake I meant we hope
you're all having a wonderful day that
unfortunate linguistic mix-up was
brought on by a force we're still
struggling to understand you see we here
at SCP explained have fallen under the
influence of a temporal anomaly commonly
referred to as opposite day you might be
under the impression that opposite day
is just something elementary school
children came up with to excuse walking
backwards and saying things they don't
mean but you would be sorely mistaken it
is all too real and no one is immune to
its confusing effects in the spirit of
opposite day which comes for us all no
matter how much we try to prepare we
decided to fire up the good old
animatron 6000 to see how this
unknowable Force might impact one of the
anomalies at the SCP Foundation we all
know what happens in the Ordinary
non-opposite World when someone looks at
scp-096's face it's one of the first
rules they tell new employees is at the
SCP Foundation don't look at the shy
guy's face but what if the effect was
reversed what if seeing scp-096's face
didn't send the creature into an
irrepressible murderous rage but rather
inspired the same mindless violence in
the ordinary person that saw it let's
start the simulation and find out
imagine if you can a world in which the
SCP Foundation did not have scp-096 in
containment or even know of its
existence it is difficult to Envision a
creature nearly synonymous with the
foundation itself living a life outside
of those reinforced concrete and steel
walls but that is the world in which Our
Story begins deep in the snow-covered
forests of a remote mountain range a
long-limmed pale humanoid creature ran
through the trees with Innocent abandon
its white skin and long thin arms and
legs allowed it to blend in with the
snow and the narrow trunks of the tree
fees providing a natural camouflage from
any Interlopers that might present a
threat the creature lived a largely
peaceful existence feeding on Roots
berries and yes some of the local
Wildlife but that's just the way things
work in nature there are predators and
prey none good or evil in the way human
beings conceive of things all just doing
their best to stay alive the creature
that does not think of itself as scp-096
had known little more than the life it
lived in the forest keeping itself
hidden from view whenever hikers or
explorers happened upon its domain he
couldn't be sure what would happen if it
was found but its instincts drove the
creature to avoid detection at all costs
but there is no way to guarantee perfect
safety in this world and as it so often
does one day something went wrong
exhausted from searching for food all
day and night the creature decided to
get some rest leaning its head against a
sturdy tree trunk and closing its eyes
for a little while it did not fall
asleep the creature wasn't capable of
sleep the way humans might think of it
but it did allow its mind to wander and
its alertness to slip it let down its
guard only for a moment but that was one
moment too many that was just enough
time for its Keen ears to miss the sound
of approaching footsteps muffled
slightly by the thick blanket of snow
covering the ground by the time it heard
one of the hikers speak it was too late
what is that I'm not sure should we get
a closer look the creature opened its
eyes to find two strangers a man and a
woman clad in heavy winter coats and
hiking gear standing just a few feet
away it turned reflexively toward the
sound and then the stranger's eyes fell
upon its face all of a sudden their
expression changed from apprehension and
curiosity to a twisted scowl a mix of
fear pain and animalistic rage the hiker
each let out a primal scream and
descended on the creature attacking it
with whatever they had on hand the woman
clawed at its face with her fingernails
and the man pulled the heavy backpack
from his shoulders and began to hit the
creature with it again and again the
creature was Far bigger and far stronger
than these two strangers and it fought
back in an attempt to defend itself it
swung its massive arms at the hikers
sending them flying in opposite
directions the woman collided with a
tree her head hitting wood with a loud
crack the man flew out of sight
disappearing over the edge of a cliff
the creature hadn't intended to hurt
them only to keep itself safe as the shy
guy began to feel Pang of guilt for the
first time in its life it heard that
horrible scream again the woman had
regained Consciousness and was resuming
her attack in full force blood dripping
from her nose and ears and staining the
White Snow Red if the shy guy was able
to speak it would have said why are you
doing this please stop I don't want to
hurt you but it couldn't say a word so
instead it decided to try and outrun the
woman instead it turned and began to
tear through the forest at a swift
unnatural gate as the woman screams
faded away into the distance as the shy
guy had suspected she could not keep up
with its inhuman speed especially not
with the injury she had sustained during
the fight but what had happened why had
she and the man with her flown into such
a violent rage something about the side
of the creature's face had set them off
it had avoided detection for so long but
it had gotten sloppy and now its home
was no longer safe there was no time to
rest the creature would have to find
another safe place to hide and soon the
last thing it wanted was another
confrontation with a stranger who would
look at its face and then erupt into
violence as the creature continued to
run leaving the thick cover of the tree
line and making its way down the
mountain he'd wondered would anyone who
saw its face react the same way perhaps
this was just a uniquely awful case
perhaps this wouldn't happen again still
it would be best to stay out of sight
better safe than sorry of course the
creature not yet known as scp-096 had
never heard that expression living a
completely solitary life void of any
idioms or classic sayings but its
feelings vis-a-vis safety and regret
were pretty much the same the creature
descended the treacherous Mountain
effortlessly navigating the unforgiving
rocky surface and deadly slicks of ice
by the time the creature had left its
Old Mountain Home behind the sun had set
and night had fallen on the wintry
landscape it slowed its stride then
listening for the sounds of approaching
potential threats but there appeared to
be no one around it was just the lone
pale creature the moon peeking out from
behind the clouds and the open unknown
World ahead after sometime walking
completely alone the creature spotted
lights up ahead it did not understand
the concept of a town but indeed that's
what it was the creature swerved away
from the majority of the lights and
stumbled upon an old wooden Barn
apparently abandoned and left to rot in
the elements this would be as good of
places any to rest for a little while to
Shelter From the incoming snowstorm and
stay out of sight so the shy guy made
itself a makeshift bed of straw and
curled up there to wait out the night as
it lay there thinking about the day
before it felt a sudden wave of grief
for its lost home for the changes that
had come into its life unbidden and
turned it all upside down the creature
covered its face with its massive hands
and began to Weep the creature was
startled from its tears when morning
came and with it the sound of someone
breaking down the rotting wood beams
that lined the barn walls it stood
looking toward the sound and saw the
woman from the mountain pale and
shivering eyes rimmed with dark circles
and face caked in dried blood she still
screamed that horrible scream tearing
away at the wood even as it ripped up
the Flesh of her hands she was missing
one Boot and her coat was torn open
scattering tiny feathers with every
movement she did not appear to feel the
cold the pain the exhaustion of chasing
the creature for so long she only wanted
one thing to destroy the creature by any
means necessary with a screech like a
banshee she left onto the creature's
back clawing at its face and eyes it
thrashed wildly throwing the woman to
the ground and running without a glance
back maybe she survived her fall onto
the cold hard ground or maybe it would
be the blow that actually finished her
off the creature's only priority was to
keep moving before something else tried
to attack what the creature didn't know
was that the citizens of the nearby town
the one that it was about to run right
into the center of in its Panic were
gathering to celebrate rate their annual
Christmas festival complete with an
early morning parade through the town
square the same town square that the shy
guy was bounding into at that exact
moment as the shy guy raced over the
cobblestone street it ran directly into
the line of sight of a full marching
band a fleet of dancers dressed in
costumes inspired by The 12 Days of
Christmas a row of young women competing
in the Miss holiday spirit pageant and a
jolly old man dressed up as Santa Claus
in his sleigh the marching band saw the
creature first Terra morphing quickly
into that same wordless rage as their
eyes fell on its face it moved to cover
itself to hide its face from view but it
was too late the marching band swarmed
around it swinging trombones and
clarinets one percussion player broken
massive drum over the creature's head in
the struggle still it was able to
withstand the musical Onslaught flinging
musicians this way and that snapping
brass instruments like twigs crushing
Woodwinds into mulch unfortunately as
the marching band was being dealt with
the commotion had drawn the attention of
the dancers and the pageant competitors
one swarm was replaced with two more as
the performers flew into a frenzy
tackling the creature to the ground and
using every item at their disposal to
try and harm it the creature bellowed
with fear and frustration prying itself
free and continuing to run this time it
actually remembered to cover its face
just in time to pass Saint Nicholas
himself how have you all gone mad the
old man had not gotten the chance to see
the creature's face for himself and was
horrified at the behavior of his friends
and neighbors what has gotten into you
the creature was preoccupied with
running and keeping his face covered so
it did not see what happened next he
could only hear the sound of the Santa
Claus impersonator confronting the mob
his scandalized shouts becoming suddenly
muffled and the troubling Sound of
Silence followed by the Thundering
Stampede of crazed villagers the man had
tried to help but there was only one of
him and there were so many others intent
on destroying the creature now so the
Shanghai continued to run for his life
listening to the Mob just behind it
never stopping to rest to eat or to
sleep whatever had filled these people
with such murderous impulse it made them
something a little removed from human
too they were sustained by the desire to
kill even when their bodies should have
given out long ago as the creature ran
it encountered honored more people that
caught a glimpse of its face that lost
themselves in the urge to destroy and
became one with a growing horde the
creature could no longer tell how long
it had been running or if it would ever
be able to stop it was strong and
seemingly invulnerable but how long
would it be until enough people were
caught in this curse until the mob was
big enough to swallow the creature whole
just when it was beginning to
contemplate giving up lying down and
letting the Sea of angry faces overtake
it a burlap bag was thrown over its head
it skidded to a stop disoriented feeling
around
here we need amnestics and lots of them
these people look nuts a voice sparked
orders as the creature felt hands
pushing it into a small enclosed space
the back of an SCP Foundation van though
of course the shine guy didn't know that
it could hear more voices whispering to
each other close by I've never seen
anything like this what is this thing
anyway stop
stop whatever you do don't look at its
face now go check out scp-096 origin
theories and scp-096 tail a lesson in
power for more tales of the shy guy